[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport bot dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist unser sohn er
ich bin selbst herr sportler und heute
zu gast haben wir parallel kanuten
markus mandy sohr oder herzlich
willkommen liebe heißt der markus
mendler und mensch ist ein zweiter
vorname nicht so wie viele glauben das
ist ein spitzname ist woher kommt der
name genau es war so also meine
großeltern waren auf urlaub auf einem
schloss metric und die haben sich also
den namen verliebt und meine eltern
haben dann auch toll gefunden aber
irgendwie hat es nicht funktioniert dass
man mich mein trick nennt und da war am
ende hat das nächste und ich gehe immer
bei meinem zweiten vornamen weil markus
gibt es einige mandy gibt es weniger
also da ist die verwechslungsgefahr
nicht sehr groß und du bist nicht mehr
über deinen namen einzigartig sondern
natürlich auch über deine sportlichen
erfolge und über deine geschichte und du
natürlich als mensch ebenso für die die
uns jetzt nur hören und nicht zuschauen
also du hast eine oberschenkel position
und eine unterschenkel amputation wie es
dazu gekommen als sie sieben jahre alt
war kurz nach schulanfang in der zweiten
klasse volksschule benehmen bei uns zu
hause in die förderschnecke unserer
geschäftsleitung gefallen die hat man
beide unterschenkel abgetrennt und in
einem versuch mit diesen abgetrennten
stücken und eine muskel aus dem rücken
ein ganzes bein zu rekonstruieren
der leider nicht ganz geklappt hat weil
aufgrund dieses wie sagt man halt
ausreißen die blutgefäße soweit im knie
kaputt waren
dass mir das rechte bein dann bis
oberhalb von knie abgestorben ist also
mit dem muskel aus dem rücken und des
war es beim unfall sonst noch alles
übrig geblieben ist
du bist jetzt mit zwei beinprothesen
unterwegs was du sofort auf prothesen
unterwegs war hat man selbst versucht
das du im rollstuhl du dich bewegst das
ist wie gesagt kurz noch schulanfang
also september oktober dann war er bis
ende november oder so im krankenhaus
dann hat der em im neuen jahr in bad
häring angefangen und bis dahin wahrheit
alles im rollstuhl prothesen waren halt
nie wirklich bequem also es ist am
anfang immer wie ein schuh drückt im bad
häring wahrheit alles rollstuhlgerecht
jetzt bin ich halt extrem mobil gewesen
im rollstuhl und das interesse an den
prozessen ist dort eher gesunken als wir
gestiegen als sieben oder dann auch
jähriger bub der extrem für durch das es
war schöne zeit aber ich hab viel machen
können den hering schwimmen im rollstuhl
durch die gegend setzen sonst alles
barrierefrei und sie haben halt die
grundlagen des gehens und so beigebracht
aber auf die prothesen verlassen habe
mich dort nicht und wie dann wieder nach
hause gekommen bin und dann waren wieder
stufen bin in die schule gegangen aber
auch stufen und auf einmal waren die
prothesen kann immer zum wegdenken also
es war dann halt fixer bestandteil
meines lebens nur dazu dem mann
daraufhin mit die anderen kinder war es
auch nötig und dann habe es jeden tag an
gehabt und dann ist das kein problem
mehr gewesen gar nicht mehr
wie ist ihr die die umstellung gefallen
ich meine wir hatten in einem ähnlichen
alter dem unfall ich war sechs damals
wie ich meinem unfall hatte und der
produktion passiert ist du warst 7
es ist ihre mitgegangen also für mich
war das überhaupt kein problem also alle
fragen ähnliche fragen also es ist mit
sieben hast du so weit noch kein eigenes
leben das die das jetzt aus den alltag
wirft oder sonst was also das ist wie
reset-knopf drücken ohne dass vor
wirklich viel passiert ist also das ist
ein 2 neustadt aber es war kein problem
bei alles was vor sieben war war jetzt
nicht unbedingt zur welt bewegen dass
sie deshalb mir große sorgen um die
zukunft hätte machen müssen
das heißt auch bei dir wahrscheinlich
dann ähnlich wie bei mir dass die
umstellung auch teil des prozesses war
dann relativ schnell abgelaufen ist und
natürlich mehr unfair war relativ heftig
und ich bin dann eben im krankenhaus
wenn er apathisch waren also hat nun
auch ins neuen castingshow derart
fernseher darum variante kurz im
krankenhaus also sie haben relativ
schnell raus also dass die
rehabilitation hat zu hause auch schon
angefangen hat und deshalb miteinander
entwicklung wahrscheinlich wieder
bisschen vorangetrieben beim im
krankenhaus da man es nur in die anecken
just ja wir dahin ganz weich und aber ja
also sie habe keine klasse wiederholen
müssen habe alles so wie vorgesehen
machen kindern also erst kommt nur eine
zweite klasse das war dann auch wieder
so ein
des weitern die erstkommunion im
frühjahr wahrheit dann sozusagen der
punkt wo man wieder zurückgekehrt ist
also ja also sich eine novität dann
wieder eingestellt genauso da hat sich
dann die neue normalität eingestellt
also nicht so wie die cdu
normalität in einem krone aber ich kann
mein leben jetzt gerne machen das
vorstellen
du bist mehrfacher weltmeister
mehrfacher europameister paralympics
medaillengewinnerin kano wie bist du
dann in oberösterreich bisher zu hause
zum kanusport gekommen es war zufällig
also mit acht jahren habe dann beim
schwimmen angefangen also war bevor mein
unfall weil wasserskifahrer weil das
mein vater auch wahr oder hat soweit man
halt mit sieben schon wasserskifahrer
sein kann dann hat das halt immer so gut
funktioniert also zum wasserskifahren
braucht man beine wir haben es zwar auch
mit den verrücktesten mechanischen
methoden probiert und es hat auch
geklappt da wahrheit wer niemals
wettkampfmäßig los möglich gewesen und
wettkampfsport wahrheit doch verankert
bei uns in der familie
jetzt habe ich schwimmen ausprobiert
wieder aber die umsätze gestiegen sein
war das irgendwie immer meins also das
ist sie fasziniert dass immer wieder wie
viele schwimmer trainieren können
und dann hat uns ein bekannter einmal
ein geschenk das hat er sie in seiner
jugend gekauft und hat schon immer
gebraucht und hat uns geschenkt und wir
waren halt für
auf der donau unterwegs und dann war mal
zufällig in unter müll haben das kag
dabei gehabt und ich bin halt gepaddelt
und dann kommen die wanderfahrer von
meinem jetzigen verein von einer
wanderfahrt vorbei und fragen ob die
nicht im verein vorbeischauen will und
seitdem bin ich partner und vor allem
das faszinierende ist ja du bist noch
bevor es den sport in dem sinne in
winnenden sport überhaupt organisiert
gegeben hat mit großen wettkämpfen und
ebenfalls paralympischen sport und hat
dadurch die zufällig anscheinend auch
einen irrsinnigen zeitvorsprung gehabt
war das auch ein element das du gedacht
hast aber es ist noch nicht
paralympischer sollte ich die sportart
überhaupt machen oder war das überhaupt
kein war wie mit sport angefangen oder
so zuerst mit dem wasserski fahren also
mein vater hat sie hat extreme schultern
einen unfall gegeben und er wollte halt
dass er mein leben möglichst normal
führe und da war hat halt normaler sport
dazugehört also zuerst beim
wasserskifahren was nicht funktioniert
hat dann schwimmen was ich nicht wollte
dann war es halt so dass wir eigentlich
nie wirklich richtung behindertensport
gedacht haben also natürlich jetzt die
möglichkeit von anfang an gegeben aber
das ist mit memc von organisch gewachsen
wie man sagt und es war halt nie die
idee dass sich an behindertensport
auszusuchen und es war auch kein problem
als sie habe bis 2010 habe ich den sport
nicht paralympische österreichischen und
internationalen niveau betrieben war
auch viele jahre bester österreicher
also in der jeweiligen altersklasse
heute und war kein problem
zur internationalen spitze war dann doch
riesenunterschied
also es war dann teilweise war es sogar
so dass die eltern manche konkurrenten
damals gesagt haben das ist ja unfair
der ist ja leichter war keine füße ja
was war sie also wo es immer heutzutage
gar nicht als vorteil also dass ich
leicht bin ja der vorteil aber die
nachteile überwiegen wenn man sie jetzt
die para kanurennen im vergleich zu
wenig behinderten rennen
was wären denn die nachteile also mal
steht sie partner immer so stur vor dass
man eigentlich alles aus den armen macht
das was eigentlich nicht stimmt also du
machst extrem für körper rotation die
aber auch im fuß schon anfang also du
drückst mit dem fuß gegen das template
dann steigst du dein knie durch rotiert
mit dem hintern am sitz und dadurch
schaffst du heute ein bisschen mehr
amplitude in der bewegung und was noch
wichtiger ist ist der also der impuls
denn der boden mit geben kannst du durch
also das ist halt mein trainer hat immer
gesagt du musst den ganzen körper
spannen wir einen bogen und sobald das
barthel auf das wasser trifft musst
loslassen also dass alles auf einmal
gleichzeitig zieht und das ist das was
mir führt dass die beine füße alles
mithilft und fährst du dann mit oder
ohne prothesen
ich bin bis dieses jahr bin ich alles
ohne prothesen gefahren und jetzt habe
immer eine adaption so weit entwickelt
dass ihr meine linke also meine
unterschenkel prothese also dann kann
ich englisch sagt malek drive also die
beiden bewegung mit meinem linken knie
machen und habe dadurch eine bessere
rotation und einen größeren impuls oft
also besonders auf der linken seite also
faszinierend sehr spannend aber das
jetzt vorhergesagt dass eben teilweise
gehältern
also ich find das da ein wahnsinn dass
die eltern der anderen dann sagen dass
du im vorteil bis der aufgrund einer
behinderung ich kann das aus den filmen
wo ich immer wieder disqualifiziert
wurde wegen einarmigen anschlages weil
er die regeln wir sagen dass man zwar
habe ich anschlagen muss das kann ich
natürlich nicht bei nichtbehinderten
wettkämpfen und da ist auch mal geld
wieder geheißen dass das ein vorteil ist
dass ich noch einen armen habe wie bist
du damit umgegangen dass du solche dinge
hörst du möchtest einen sport machen
gemeinsam mit deinen freunden ohne
behinderung und dann hast du solche
sachen wie ist das hobby erst dieses
jahr gehört also ich kann jetzt also für
mich war das jetzt nie nie wirklich
einen unterschied
natürlich habe ich gewusst ich bin
behindert aber jetzt einen keine
unterschiede gesehen bei der ausübung
des sports also und die haupt dass jetzt
dieses jahr gehört dass wir sie darüber
aufregen hat und dann kommen dann doch
eher schmunzeln auswahl
jetzt betreibt man den sport dann nach
zehn jahren nicht behindert sozusagen
zehn jahre behindert und dann muss man
über solche aussagen einfach wenn man
also ja also ich mich fasziniert dass
ich immer wieder wie wie die gedanken so
flexibel sein kann dass man sagt ich
glaube das problem ist einfach bei
besonders also was jetzt so eine
einzelsportart wie schwimmen betrifft
das dort seien dann die und gegen die
emotionen so hoch also besonders
bekannte deren tochter schwimmt und dies
kann sich aufregen über handelt dann und
die war also dies jetzt 14 15 also wie
gesagt bis dahin geht sowieso um die
goldene ananas also wie kann man das ein
drama draus machen ja der sport
emotionalisiert halt anders die eltern
im eltern bereich du hast auf jeden fall
nicht nur im licht behindertenbereich
und dann im fahrsport deinen sport
erfolgreich ausgeübt da was in dem sind
ein optimales inklusions beispiel noch
bevor das überhaupt gesellschaftlich so
eine rolle gespielt hat wie es wir sind
deine kollegen damit umgegangen dass du
als sportler mit behinderung gemeinsam
mit ihnen gepaddelt hast am anfang hat
sicher berührungsängste gegeben aber ich
bin jetzt nicht unbedingt schwer
behindert oder auch waren jetzt im
rollstuhl sitzen würde wäre es natürlich
um einiges schwieriger besonders im
kartsport weil doch viel über stufen
stattfindet dass es gibt glaube ich nur
eine barrierefrei sportanlage in
österreich und in kalk sport zu
betreiben
aber ja also natürlich meine prothesen
haben alles viel leichter gemacht und es
war also da wir miteinander aufgewachsen
seien eigentlich kein problem was
inklusion betrifft jetzt möchte ich dann
kurz auf rio
das große sportliche highlight bisher
haben wir beide unsere erste
paralympische medaille gemacht ich beim
dritten versuch da hat doch was beim
aller ersten mal dort weil deine
sportart erst da paralympic geworden ist
und ich erinnere mich dass wir uns
riesig gefreut haben wie du die
silbermedaille gemacht hast
ich hatte aber das gefühl dass du nicht
ganz hundertprozentig zufrieden dass das
er dem sport jahrelang dominiert
dann war plötzlich andere auch noch da
die auf einem niveau waren wir in diesen
momenten damals gegangen
also wir haben drei niveaus gehabt also
das niveau des ersten dann das niveau
des zweiten und des niveau das ich war
immer noch so weit vor der konkurrenz
wie immer nur der erste fand nur für wen
er da vor mir und das ist das was weh
getan hat und jetzt ihr habe überhaupt
kein problem aber halt einfach also über
mit meiner leistung selber auch
zufrieden bis ich den abstand gesehen
habe also es ist die zeit wenn jetzt
schlecht aber es war einfach der abstand
so groß da sind wir doch was habe ich
die jahre gemacht was habe ich falsch
gemacht also aber ja man muss nach vorne
schauen
neben jahr darauf war der abstand auf
einmal nur noch halb so groß natürlich
ist ein nach olympisches jahr immer oder
ein nachbar olympisches jahr immer etwas
anderes weil man weiß nicht wie viele
andere trainiert hat ich kann nur sagen
ich hab es aber auch wichtig aber
abstand ist trotzdem damit dass
geschmolzen aber seitdem wieder um
einiges größer geworden also ich habe
einige defizite gehabt das war nicht
leicht die letzten jahre also es ist die
situation vor corona war nicht unbedingt
jetzt leicht für mich in österreich als
einziger fahrer kanuten nur dazu da ein
trainer mit rio aufgehört hat und zurück
nach ungarn gegangen ist wie pflegen
heute immer noch guten kontakt aber es
ist halt schwierig immer alleine zu sein
und du hast du dafür jetzt eine lösung
gefunden trainierst du mit anderen
trainingsgruppen im ausland mit oder wie
läuft das genau also bis corona
angefangen hat ja seitdem ich wer
besonders jetzt mit diesen steigenden
fallzahlen usw ist einfach alles
unsicher dass sie nicht am
trainingslager im ausland bemühen möchte
weil es ist wäre also ob es
unverantwortlich ist bei aller vorsicht
möchte ich nicht sagen aber es ist
einfach
so unsicher mit den maßnahmen dass es
relativ leicht in die hose gehen kann
dann bin ich zurück komme vielleicht
zwei wochen zu hause eingesperrt oder
halt in quarantäne
und das ist dann das macht das ganze
nicht leicht aus dem wie dann in
oberösterreich die steigenden fallzahlen
waren wollte ich nach ungarn fahren in
der woche dann habe ich mir an dem
abreisetag nicht optimal gefüllt und
dann haben die umgang gesagt und so war
es dann gar nicht verpackung die gesamte
zeit war er sicher trainings technisch
auch eine große herausforderung wie hast
du das für dich gelöst ich bin kurz vorm
ersten lockdown aus dem trainingslager
zurück gekommen
wie ist dann am wochenende geheißen hat
ab montag ist alles zu haben wir ein
boot aus dem bootshaus geholt aufs
autodach gelegt und bin dann den ab
mitte märz bis mai vom auto ausgestattet
also ich mich im auto umgezogen bin
habsburg genommen bin zum wasser
gegangen eingestiegen und von dort das
dann das training gemacht also wir haben
zu hause eine klimmzug stange und
liegestütze gänge nach überall aber das
war großteils mein training natürlich
habe ich den luxus dass sie zu meiner
mama nach hause ins land
das land habe gehen können das heißt wir
haben einfach nur die räder nehmen
kinder und haben vom haus staaten kinder
also wir haben teilweise städter gehabt
sie heute vor unserer haustür geparkt
haben um spazieren zu gehen und da war
es dann einmal ziemlich fies weil ich
habe meine e-mail bekommen weil das
sport austria hat empfohlen hat sport
nur von zu hause aus zu machen und dann
kommen die leute aus der stadt bis für
unsere haustiere spazieren zu gehen aber
wenn ich in die stadt fahre um partner
zu gehen ist das auf einmal böse so was
man für der kanuverband verkaufen wollen
ich habe gesagt das ist eine empfehlung
leute ich bin dort alleine bin niemandem
im weg
ja bin an zwei polizeistreifen im boot
vorbei gelaufen die haben mir fragt ob
es eine zweite sohn nicht auch etwas
falsch mache also überhaupt kein großes
problem im ersten lockern
und jetzt dass profisportler ist alles
erlaubt oder hat so gut wie alles und
als einzelsportler ohne trainingsgruppe
habe jetzt überhaupt keine probleme also
jetzt im zweiten block dann und den
sommer über haben wir wettkämpfe gehabt
was auch nicht schlecht war was
internationales highlight war ein
weltcup ende september in ungarn er war
bei den nichtbehinderten sehr gut
besucht bei die behinderten waren in
einem rennen vier statt dem anderen
rennen 5 statt da was mir nicht
unbedingt sehr glücklich gemacht hat ich
habe mit meiner leistung im ausleger
habe aufzeigen können im kajak bin ich
gegen leute gefahren die normalerweise
nicht ins finale kommen das war jetzt
nicht unbedingt große herausforderung
dort zu gewinnen
aber ja die leute sagen wir gewinnen
muss man trotzdem also ich bin jetzt
nicht unglücklich aber er hat mir über
größere konkurrenz gefreut um zu sehen
wo mein moment ist und was aber nicht
mehr wettkämpfe bestritten und viel
trainiert du hast auch längere touren am
wasser gemacht
2 in der zahl wie kann man sich das
genau vorstellen und was passiert da
genau
ich habe relativ lange spitz top jetzt
die spiele verschoben werden also es ist
die europameisterschaft war schon
verschoben und die olympischen spiele
haben 2020 und somit auch die
paralympics 2020 stattfinden müssen
und das hat halt extrem also mir
sportler extrem unter stress gesetzt
weil man sieht dann andere nationen wie
die normal trainieren und du selber
startet dann vom auto aus und das hat
extremen stress pur sagt und wieder seit
dann verschoben worden ist haben wir
doch so kurz urlaub also dieses jahr
geht es ja ich war von passau bis
hainburg habe das zufällig einem freund
gesagt die letzten vier tage vorgenommen
und ja gesagt meer oder am wochenende
was zu tun vielleicht fordern nur bis
krems mit oder hoffen was dann in drei
tage fahren also 340 kilometer in drei
tagen am ersten tag seiner von passau
nach linz gefahren was gut
weil da haben wir dann zu hause schlafen
können am zweiten tag von linz nach
krems was 125 km/h hat mir dann meine
freunde motto besucht aber im auto
schlafen gehen einmal freund hatte in
seinem zelt geschlafen und dann von
krems bis hainburg was nummer 125
kilometer seien also das war tolle tour
zweiter war nicht unbedingt ideal aber
es war wohl schön haben wir die ganze
österreichische donau abgefahren zu sein
und das hat man anscheinend so sehr
gefallen dass sie dann noch eine tour
gemacht habe von grün bis nach linz was
440 kilometer seien als 100 da mehr
dafür wenn man sechs tage zeit genommen
also ich hab mal mehr zeit genommen aber
ich bin sondern sechs tage gefahren also
ich hab mir das nicht ziemlich stressen
müssen es war aber wunderbar und ich
habe alles was ich mitnehmen musste
dabei gehabt als er dann relativ schwer
unterwegs gewesen habe auch immer im
zelt geschlafen also keine hotels also
jobs geschafft ohne einmal einkaufen zu
gehen also ich hab alles am ersten tag
ins boot gepackt und es ist halt mit der
zeit leicht aber am letzten abend der
tour am vorletzten tag hat mir meine
freundin wieder besucht und wir haben im
hotel in der schlinge geschlafen was
auch nicht da also ausklang war und dann
am nächsten tag habe ganz leicht dass er
nur boot und flaschenwasser die letzten
50 kilometer fahren können und da kann
man sich das so vorstellen dass da
wirklich stundenlang am tag auf der
donau im boot
huddlestone genau wie man von passau
nach hamburg fahren langsamer am tag ca
12 stunden im boot gesessen und 14
stunden unterwegs gewesen also es ist
halt ein bisschen was von meditieren
also meist und von von von ulm nach linz
neben ausleger gefahren also da habe
dann habe die stabilität gehabt von
diesem ausleger und da habe ich dann
halt zwischendurch handy oder einfach
nur belasten können aber da bin ich
eigentlich für gar nichts aus kriegen
also gut gegessen und so weiter nur
waren heute kraftwerke oder sonstwas
waren habe auch stecken müssen um
vorbeizukommen
aber das ist wirklich nur auf der donau
unterwegs unternehmen spätestens um halb
neun im boot gesessen und frühestens um
6 gestiegen also das wunderbare
ablenkung weil man verliert einfach
diesen also einen realitätsbezug ist
jetzt für euch aber manchmal kriegt
einfach so wenig mit und wir es einfach
mit sich selbst beschäftigt dass alles
andere einfach eine zeit lang und
wichtig erscheint und man ist auch in
direkten kontakt mit der natur was du
natürlich im sport sowieso bis das auch
etwas was dir viel gibt also die partner
täglich auf der donau und dann zu sehen
was da alles noch gibt also besonders
gefallen hat man der donaudurchbruch
also man kann sie die schlögener
schlinge vorstellen
zimmer ghana und alles fertig also es
war wunderschön und auch bis pass aber
die donnersmarck grün und komplett klar
da passt kommt der in dazu dann kommt
der fahrer seine cracks suppen oder ist
es wahnsinn
aber es war also es war wunderbar
ich hab was sie an vögel gesehen habe in
dieser kraftwerks bereiche wo hat fast
keine strömung ist was dann folgte war
haben sie alle sog von mädchen dabei 500
meter nachwuchs an die open
ja aber es war schön also in der anstalt
hat der verein also im hafen wo er 30
mal die die ratten extrem in die steine
am ufer und dann kommen so sexy am abend
beim bei meinem glaube es war der dritte
abend kommen und an sander die die
katzen die diese hatten jürgen
das war wohl dass es auf jeden fall
einiges schon gesehen ich habe hier noch
ganz kurz zum abschluss stehen
dass du auch mal über dem atlantik
paddeln möchtest von den kanarischen
inseln bis in die karibik ganz alleine
du das bloß und das meer und das ganze
30 tage dauern
wann hast du das vor ja also während
meiner aktiven zeit wird das was das
eigentlich nie rein also ich hab mal da
gibt es die teile ska whisky atlantic
challenge astes das ist ein ruderrennen
von den kanarischen inseln in die
karibik es sagen glaube ich gut 3000
seemeilen oder so und ja da wird täglich
also die die rudern der heute im einer
zweier vierer dreier und so weiter und
die wird heute gerne das eben kein
knoten also es ist gibt halt immer diese
verwendung inzwischen die ruderer und
die kajak fahrer und das im ruderboot zu
machen das wird mir ziemlich für
überwindung kosten aber im kalk wird zum
extrem interessieren so was mal zu
machen
und wie gesagt das ist halt dieses waren
täglich ist und gibt die eigentlich
nichts außer wasser dann ist ist alles
auf einmal so unwichtig und die idee ist
man eigentlich gekommen wie damals
dieser terroranschlag auf diesem
deutschen adventmarkt war weil das dann
halt so schreckensnachrichten die das
leben aller irgendwie beeinflussen die
dann zwei wochen später für unbeteiligte
schon wieder wurst sein aber das wird ja
gar nicht aufhören und dann hast du
wirklich 30 tage oder 40 je nachdem wie
lang man braucht seelenfrieden weiter
natürlich hast du dann bis zum anderen
stresssituationen also was dann eher in
richtung überlebenskampf geht als wie
jetzt
sie sorgen zu machen aufwand adventmarkt
zu gehen und das ist das was mir
besonders reizt und da muss man extrem
cool feuchte was man es dann wirklich
nur von kilometern von kilometern wasser
umgeben bis kein licht zu sehen nur die
sterne so das muss tor sein also dass
auf jeden fall noch einige
herausforderungen vor die auch neben
einer sportlichen natürlich auch die
paralympics nächstes jahr wir wünschen
dir alles gute
danke dass du hier beim sport reporter
ich danke danke wände und danke euch
dass ihr heute beim sport report dabei
was wir freuen uns aufs nächste mal bis
dann
[Applaus]